we're now going to talk about the
beginnings of one of the most important
religions in human history and even
today the largest religion on earth and
that of course is Christianity and the
central figure in Christianity is Jesus
Christ and the term Christ is given to
him it is Greek for Savior or for
Messiah because his early followers view
him as the prophesize Messiah Savior for
the Jewish people and his followers
today view him as the Savior the Messiah
for all humankind so we have over 2
billion Christians who view him central
to their faith who view them him as
their God but above and beyond that you
also have over a billion Muslims who
view him as a significant profit now
just to get some context on the life and
times of Jesus most of our about the
accounts we have of him come from the
first four books of the New Testament of
the Bible called the Gospel of Matthew
Gospel of Mark Gospel of Luke Gospel of
John sometimes it's the Gospel according
to Matthew Mark Luke or John and the
term gospel today often refers to the
idea of the life and teaching of Jesus
Christ so you could view it as a life
and teaching of Jesus Christ according
to Matthew according to Mark according
to Luke according to John but it really
comes from Old English for good news
good news and there's a related term
Evangel you might have heard evangelical
or evangelize also referring to good
news now the reason why it was
considered good news is his message then
we're going to have some examples of it
in a few minutes
really talks about this idea that the
poor have the Kingdom of Heaven waiting
for them that there's this forgiving God
that you can have a close connection
with and for a lot of people remember
this was in the time of the Roman Empire
most people were downtrodden there was
slavery people were poor and this idea
that even the poor could go to the
Kingdom of Heaven and and and in some
ways have better access to it than the
rich and the powerful was good news to a
lot of people now it's worth noting that
these Gospels were written several
decades after
the depending what you view the death or
an or ascension of Jesus Christ
according to Christian belief as you can
see Jesus was born slightly before the
year one most historians put his birth
that around four to six BCE before the
Common Era and they put his death around
30 to 33 C II in the Common Era you
could also use the original terms before
Christ and anno domini in the year of
our Lord our modern calendar system is
really uses the the the original view of
the birth of Jesus as where we start
anno domini verses before Christ or the
Common Era versus the before the Common
Era now it's interesting that it turns
out that Jesus was likely born slightly
before slightly before the purported the
original view on the birth of Christ
now his birth would have been right
around the time or it would have been
under the reign of Emperor Augustus as
we talked about in in other videos and
his death would have been under the
reign of emperor Tiberius and these
Gospels mark Matthew Luke and John these
are written during really hard time for
the Jewish people and for the early
Christians you have the Jewish rebellion
where the Second Temple is destroyed by
Rome you have the significant Christian
persecution especially by folks like
Emperor Nero where he blames the fire in
Rome on Christians and then he just
essentially kills them for fun for you
know just really just to purge them to
persecute them and just to understand
where all of this takes place the life
and times of Jesus takes place it is in
the Roman Empire we're in on the eastern
edge of it at the eastern Mediterranean
right over here this would be modern-day
Israel and Palestine for the most part
this is a zoomed in version and Jesus is
born in Bethlehem and this is a scene
I'm going to show you a lot of paintings
as you could imagine he's a figure that
has inspired a lot of paintings this is
a figure of the Three Magi giving
visiting and giving their gifts to the
infant Jesus Magi famously the
Zoroastrian priests coming from Persia
to visit
Jesus according to biblical accounts and
he is raised in Nazareth and that's why
he's oftentimes referred to as Jesus of
Nazareth and the Gospels don't talk a
lot about his early life they start to
talk a lot about his life in his once he
hits his late 20s or early 30s and the
first really significant account after
his famous birth to the Virgin Mary his
purported father he has Joseph was
Mary's husband but that the Holy Ghost
or God was the actual father making this
a virgin birth but after that the first
significant event is really his baptism
by John the Baptist John the Baptist was
another preacher prophetic figure of
that time a significant one he had a lot
of followers and he was baptizing people
in the Jordan River right in that region
this is Jordan River right over here and
this is a depiction of the famous
baptism of Jesus by John the Baptist and
famously John the Baptist said no you
should be baptizing me but then after
you said no no you baptize me and after
Jesus was baptized famously
kind of the Sun shines on Jesus and God
speaks that this is my son according to
once again biblical accounts and John
the Baptist shortly after that gets
arrested by King Herod of Galilee
remember Galilee is the home region of
Jesus where he will eventually do his
most of his preaching and after that
Jesus starts to really go full into fact
in his ministry and while he's doing
that he's performing all of these
miracles he's healing people turning
water into wine walking on water
bringing people back from the dead and
this is of course according to biblical
accounts you can decide if you believe
these or not and he does most of that in
Galilee and eventually he makes his way
down to Jerusalem to meet his fate he
tells according to the gospel his
followers his disciples and there's 12
in particular that are called out but he
has many many more than that that look I
am going to meet my
my fate there but I'm going I'm doing it
willingly but more than his miracles
it's interesting to look at some of what
he preached and this might give you a
little bit of a sense why many people
would have called this good news so this
is from the Gospel of Matthew that I'm
going to quote right over right over
here and this first part it comes from
his sermon of the mount or sermon of
well he goes to the top of mountain and
he gives this sermon and blessed are the
poor in spirit for theirs is the kingdom
of heaven blessed are the meek for they
shall inherit the earth
blessed are the merciful for they shall
obtain mercy blessed are the pure in
heart for they shall see God blessed are
the peacemakers for they shall be called
sons of God so all of that if you're you
know if you're a peasant if you're
someone with not a lot your downtrodden
hard life you're like look blessed are
the poor in spirit for theirs is the
kingdom of heaven you could view this as
good news ye have heard that it was said
an eye for an eye and a tooth for tooth
but I say unto you resist not him that
is evil but whosoever smite thee on thy
right cheek turn to him the other also
even in modern times this is not an easy
way this is not an easy way to live
someone who's doing something to you
don't try to seek revenge and this is a
very different tone than a lot of what
you might get in the Old Testament ye
have heard that it was said thou shalt
love thy neighbor and hate that enemy
but I say unto you love your enemies and
pray for them that persecute you once
again not an easy thing to do and even
in modern terms what you could view this
is a very forward a very advanced way of
thinking about the world he also beyond
this idea of kind of embracing even your
enemies and not seeking revenge and that
the poor can have access to this kingdom
of heaven he really also like to take it
to the hypocrites especially those who
viewed themselves as the bearers of the
religion in particular he picks on the
Pharisees which was a sect of Jews at
the time who viewed themselves very
ritualistic remember Jesus himself is a
Jewish preacher he's a Jewish teacher he
is viewed as a rabbi himself and when ye
pray ye shall not be as the hypocrites
for they love to stand and pray in the
synagogues and in the corners of the
street that they may be see
of men so these hypocrites they pray
just so other people can see how
religious they are verily I say unto you
they have received their war they've
already gotten the credit for people for
praying but thou when thou prayest enter
into thy an inner chamber and having
shut thy door pray to thy father who is
in secret and thy father who see it in
secret shall recompense these so don't
make a big deal about your prayer do it
in private and then have this personal
connection with God now it's worth
noting that even though he preached a
lot about about the Kingdom of Heaven
for the poor that you know prayer is a
private thing that you should you
shouldn't try to seek revenge you should
be very conciliatory to your enemies he
did take a strong stance on what he was
preaching he did say look you got to be
with me if you want to enter into this
kingdom of heaven he took some strong
stances that this isn't going to be an
easy thing and this is going to cause a
lot of tension this is one quote that
you could view that way once again from
the Gospel of Matthew think not that I
came to send peace on earth I came not
to send peace but a sword for I came to
set a man at variance against his father
and the daughter against her mother I
would interpret this as saying this is
gonna cost a lot cause a lot of divisive
'no sand the daughter-in-law against her
mother-in-law and a man's foes shall be
they of his own household he that loveth
father or mother more than me is not
worthy of me and he that loveth son or
daughter more than me is not worthy of
me and he that dot does not take his
cross and follow after me is not worthy
of me he that findeth his life shall
lose it and he that Luther loses his
life for my sake shall find it so he
takes a pretty strong stance that you
look you you really need to follow me
but if you follow me there's some very I
guess you say good things that are
waiting for you but eventually he does
make his way he tells his there's other
you know these miracles he's performing
this is the famous Transfiguration of
Christ where he makes it apparent to his
followers he kind of becomes Lumet
luminescent and and he becomes apparent
to his followers his disciples that he
truly is the Son of God and then he
makes his way now this is now the year
depending on whether you think it's
thirty thirty-one thirty-two
thirty-three see
he makes his way to Jerusalem to meet
his fate that he's already prophesized
to his followers that this is going to
be a tough fate that he's going to meet
he's going to die there and this is a
very important week in Christianity it's
referred to passion referred to as
Passion Week and the term passion has a
different connotation it really means
the suffering of Christ this is the week
that he suffers it's the week that he
gets crucified and resurrected so he
goes to Jerusalem on Sunday and this is
around the time of Passover a very
important a religious period for the
Jewish people and he comes to Jerusalem
the time of near Passover that Sunday
that he comes is now celebrated as Palm
Sunday
this is imagery of it where he's coming
and some people are greeting him to
Jerusalem is kind of a king they're
laying down these palms before his path
then this is the famous where he goes to
the the main temple at Jerusalem and he
cleanses it of the moneychangers he's
like hey by doing these money
transactions here you are defiling the
temple then on Thursday of that week he
has the famous Last Supper
some people believe this is the Passover
setter or seeder most historians don't
think it is but he's meeting with his 12
disciples and he's saying one of you is
going to betray me and it's Judas
Iscariot who does and he goes to the the
religious court and he says hey I have
this guy who you guys don't like
remember this whole time that Jesus is
doing his ministry he's really he's
sticking it in a lot of ways he's
calling out the these Pharisees and
these these these religious officials as
hypocrites he's getting all of these
followers a lot of these traditionalists
are saying this guy is blaspheming he's
saying he's the son of God he's saying
all of these things he's doing these
miracles on the Sabbath when you're not
supposed to be doing anything and so
Judas Iscariot goes to the the Sanhedrin
and says hey I have this guy come and
get him and they get Jesus and this is
the famous trial of Jesus by the
Sanhedrin and they say hey you've been
saying all these things we think you're
blaspheming and Jesus stays silent for
the most part so they deem him guilty
and they hand him over to the Roman
governor Pontius Pilate and they say hey
like this guy is trying to create an
insurrection against Rome which the
Romans take very seriously
and in the Bible it
looks they have him seeing seeming
somewhat reluctantly saying okay do we
really need to do this but then he says
all right if that's the way L want it
and so the Romans crucified Jesus and
this is what is now viewed as Good
Friday the crucifixion of Jesus and then
on Sunday and this was predicted by
Jesus to his followers he he is
resurrected he leaves the tomb where he
was where he was and this is a very
important week if Palm Sunday
you have Good Friday and then you have
the resurrection and then another very
very important event to Christians is 40
days after the resurrection so after 40
days he's over that forty days after the
resurrection he's seen by his followers
he's seen by many people he continues to
preach and then you have the Ascension
where he goes to the kingdom of heaven
now I'm going to leave you with a quote
by a famous Christian historian and it's
a fascinating one it says and it's very
clear because we ready just talked about
the crucifixion and you see a cross at
every Church Christianity is the only
major religion to have as its central
event the humiliation of its God as dr.
Bruce Shelley and whether you believe in
Christianity or you don't believe
whether you're an atheist whether you
believe in the miracles or you don't
it's worth pointing out the Christianity
has grown from this religion that
started around this preacher in in
Galilee and Judea and now has over two
billion adherents and what was it about
this religion and the central event
being the humiliation of its God that
made it so appealing to many especially
in that early Roman Empire both to Jews
and to non-jews to Gentiles and has made
it such a significant religion